put up your sword
the enemy is still out there
the question now is where
it is over you have not seen what i've
seen i have seen my share
you have not seen
what i have seen so to start here given
that shadow of the past is the name of
the very first episode can you both
tease how the shadow of the past looms
over your characters and also how
they're reacting to it to start at least
so i think
hal brand's past
is lingering in his mind um and it has
been for quite a long time in his life
and i think the series picks up for him
at the point where he's
cutting it off and he's saying i don't
want anything to do with my past i'm i'm
going to move away from it i'm going to
start a new life start a fresh life and
then he runs into
uh
gallatrial and a few things change yeah
um gladreal is still reeling from having
lost her brother finrod who was
slain by margoth this is a brother that
should have had forever and ever and
ever
um and she's convinced that they haven't
the damage hasn't been fixed the
darkness hasn't been snuffed out just
yet
okay so that's that's where they start
they intersect early on
can you can you each tell me something
about the other character that your
character needs like for example
something about galadriel that's really
important for hal brand to have in his
life right now and vice versa
i think
i think when hal brand sees galadriel he
whether or not i think i'll leave it
open to interpretation as to if he knows
exactly who she is i have an answer but
i think he knows that what he does know
is that there's something special about
her and he sees an opportunity and
potentially a way out of the predicament
that he's in when he meets her it's life
or death for him he's on a raft and he's
probably going to die without help um
and she provides an opportunity of
solace and safety
yeah and i think for gladial it's
slightly similar she much to her
surprise and
like surprise of everyone because she's
gradual she finds herself needing help
um which is very new for her
um and
how grams happens to be there um
it's it's a meeting that shouldn't have
happened
and somehow it does
i always like digging into shows and
movies after seeing them but you're all
doing a really good job of teasing
what's to come and hyping me up even
more than i was before
uh
more given that we have seen galadriel
in the films can you name one thing
about caitlyn chet's performance that
you really wanted to include in your own
portrayal to kind of connect the dots
but then what's something that you
deliberately strove to do different to
further convey that she is at a
different point in her life right now
okay um so i think the thing i
definitely wanted to include and the
thing that terrified me when i first saw
those films is that gladreal can be
terrifying should she choose to
she's lethal
um and so i really wanted to have that
element of that this is someone
choosing not to use
the power that they have
badly um and then something that is very
different about the galadriel of the
second age is
things are about to happen that she
couldn't comprehend and
one of those is the rings and the rings
really show the elves that they are
corruptable in a way that i don't think
they could completely comprehend before
can't wait to see more
so
charlie for you you get to play an
entirely original character here and
i've got to imagine that is super
exciting but also maybe a little
daunting given how beloved these
characters and the world are so what is
something about your portrayal of him
that
is something new to this world that
you're really excited for viewers to see
for the very first time but then also
what's something that you strove to do
so that he feels like i guess like a
natural extension of the pre-existing
world that everyone has known from
before yeah so i i think the beauty of
hal is that he
he's built upon the foundations of
of tolkien right so the show runners and
the writers did such a fantastic job in
creating a character that already has
so many uh tolkien themes built in
already and drawn from he he's really in
touch with nature and his craft and a
whole bunch of things that already exist
in tolkien um as far as bringing
something
new
i think
what we tried to go in a slightly
different direction in terms of
his voice and a bit of characterization
and physicalization we were working with
the amazing leith mcpherson who is it
was an incredible
linguist and dialect coach on this show
um
so yeah there's some interesting things
going on there
there was a time when the world was so
young
there had not yet been a sunrise
but even then
there was light
all right maximum coming your way first
so the showrunners have compared isildur
to michael corleone from the godfather
so other than him being the son of this
situation what is it about him that
makes him the michael of the family oh
he is
um
i guess in a way he is trying to do the
right thing which is
fit into society and follow his father's
footsteps and
uh
become do the societal norm but there's
something in him that is
unsettled and restless that makes him
want to escape want to leave and he
there's a romantic notion in him about
leaving and escaping and seeing the
world for himself i think it's like a
coming-of-age story
in a way
um and he makes a lot of mistakes on the
way um
but then he
he has a lot of conviction in in
whatever he's doing
okay i mean don't we all make some
mistakes along the way he makes a pretty
big mistake eventually though
well maybe it'll be perceived that the
mistake that he might make you'll
understand it and you'll be rooting for
him and you'll see it as a tragedy
and you'll be like
no
you know rather than like idiot
okay i'm open-minded i'll i'll accept
that tease and roll with it for now uh
lloyd how about for you is allen deal
comparable to veto at all what is his
approach to being the patriarch of the
family like well i was just saying if
that's true about um about corleone that
makes me brando right
i'm taking that
i'm taking it i might talk like that a
little bit
pretty good
yeah thank you
can you keep doing that yeah look my
claim to my current claims of fame is i
am 38th great great great grandfather of
vigo mortensen as aragorn right well
aragorn himself so the family line is
good it looks the looks do pass down the
looks passed down yeah and then it
stopped at the ceiling
it skipped one yes um
look tremendous responsibility to play
this role because
he's or you know he's mentioned
throughout the lord of the rings the
book is there and and there's so many
references back to him so but great
excitement because there are only
ultimately signposts that tolkien has
written on the way to who this man is
but we have to understand that he's
going to end up helping to lead the last
alliance of elves and men how does he
get there from the position and i think
in his case like like so many of
tolkien's themes it's the hero's journey
in the sense that he does not want to be
the man that is asked to take on that
amount of responsibility
so how does he how does he swallow his
his fear and his pride
to step forward and what does he have to
sacrifice to get there in terms of
family and that's what the showrunners
have set up brilliantly with our with
our family here i'm so eager to dig into
the layers of that so now emma for you
you get an exciting opportunity with a
brand new character here so can you give
us a little tease of what the dynamic is
like between her her brother and her
father yes i mean i i play aerion and
she's the baby of the family
um
and
she's we meet her at a point in her life
where she's kind of juggling her own
ambition she's quite smart and and
capable
um but of course on the cusp of
womanhood so still quite naive and
insecure
um
we're raised by single father um and
she's she's trying desperately to fill
the mother-shaped hole um and be a bit
of a mum to her older yeah
need mom but
but more troubled uh brother
um
yeah
and also
sorry and
because of the fact that she's in this
mother role that she does feel a bit
overlooked by her father
um which makes her quite vulnerable to
attention from other places
it's a lot to work with right now we
also know that she's i believe an artist
and an aspiring architect and designer
so can you tell us a little bit about
what inspired those passions in her and
what she also strives to do with them
well her mother her mother drew quite
significantly my you know my my main
prop in the show is is an is a notebook
filled with her drawings that she's that
i've sort of
you know um
become obsessed with and i'm using to
fill with my own drawings the beautiful
thing about numenoreans and the thing we
we as a people
take most pride in is the fact that we
our whole nation was created with with
our own hands and our own minds
um in contrast to the elves who have
access to you know long life and you
know
uh you know yeah anyways um they have
given us the odd skill which we'll have
to say that they yes they they've gifted
us health and and
intelligence and poetry she's going to
renovate
she's going to renovate numenor so it's
pretty exciting she's designing season 2
exactly at the minute she's just doing
the interior design to the flat
but soon to be bigger scale at the
minute she's got her fingers crossed
that she'll make an apprentice you know
apprenticeship somewhere
i mean this is all what i figured i
figured you're going to build all the
sets for season two now right correct
but the point is that the the new
challenge numenorean society is
incredibly egalitarian
there's like a town square anyone can
speak up politically anyone can say
whatever they look they like there are
all these various skills for all these
various skills and women are allowed in
those gills and they are in certain
positions within society and so that's
reflective again over here on his
position right
all right i dig it so maximum i'm coming
back to this because
obviously a very big question here but
given that we know what he sildore does
it does feel necessary to ask this with
what he does ultimately with the ring is
that something that you have to block
out while playing him in season one or
are you actively i guess planting the
seeds for him to make that decision in
the future
i think that's a question for down the
line it's more of a question for the for
the viewer as well watching him
observing him seeing
the choices that he makes as a young
adult how does that influence him later
on down the line um i know that that i i
definitely
wanted to to create a character that was
very relatable that someone that you
could watch and see yourself in um a lot
of the problems that he faces i think
maybe you would have faced at some point
in life you know
um
and he's someone who's emotional as well
someone who
uh thrives off feeling that that doesn't
necessarily necessarily think rationally
about the choices that he's doing and in
the process he loses things along the
way
also i think i mean i think just that it
always has to be pointed out that if if
if uh if gollum wasn't there would frodo
have done the uh done the same as his
hildor i think you have to answer yes
it's an especially exciting creative
challenge to have to be able to play a
character with everybody watching the
show knowing where he winds up so i am
excited to dig into the nuance you just
explained it's almost the interesting
thing is the how you know we all know
what happens but it's the how does it
happen
it will be the end not just of our
people
but all
peoples
[Music]
i am sorry
but their time has come
so obviously there is a good deal of
secrecy around this series in general
but it does feel like that's especially
strong with your character so it was me
making me wonder at what point did you
fully find out who you'd be playing in
the series and then also have either of
you come close to slipping and revealing
any secrets yet
it's such a relief to be able to talk
about them because i've been fit to
burst to be quite honest with you for
the past year
but yeah i guess it was um
when did we find out that's a good
question because it wasn't during the
audition process you know so you know
when it came to casting
uh you know all of the characters had
aliases which they continued to have
throughout the production so you had to
remember a person's name their alias
their other alias you know is a lot of
you know uh mystery around that so i
remember having an alias i remember
having sides that were sort of vague and
and written specifically just for
audition purposes
and i believe even when i was cast i
still didn't fully know
you know sort of who exactly i was
playing
um
it might have been when i got to new
zealand
but i i mean you know it really was one
of those things where i didn't i just
knew i was part of the show and and that
in and of itself was a triumph and and
exciting it was like great i'm gonna you
know we'll find out when we get there
like what's what's going on so
um once i had a better understanding of
who i was playing um
well then suddenly it was like oh well
okay
um and i benefit my my sort of uh my
secret weapon my husband is a massive
tolkien fan huge
so even when i sort of said the name you
know it's you know he sort of connected
the dots and and then it was like oh
okay well wow that's pretty freaking
cool yeah yeah i did a lot of detective
work yeah you have to yeah yeah and then
oh it's this so we were you know when
you talk to people you know on
like jd patrick and everybody you'd be
going so
about this and about donnelly
how does how does he know but we will we
all
okay we won't mention any names but
we'll just
how do we go about getting this
character then you know so yeah i've
done a little bit of detective work and
so yeah i'd uh i'd managed to deduce
who i was playing i was also pretty good
about holding on to the secret as well
because you know
being in new zealand was a benefit
because you're literally physically
removed from you know your people
and when i left for new zealand i just
told everyone i'm going somewhere
can't say where
it'll all be clear soon it'll all make
sense
um but even once people knew i was
working on lord of the rings um
you know there were a lot of guesses a
lot of people thought i would they asked
me about my ears a lot of people were
like do you have
do you have pointy ears and i i just
smiled coily and you know i just said
i'll
you'll see soon enough but i could as
well but also as well when i was doing
my detective work you have such a lovely
sort of energy you know you walk with
grace this kind of ethereal quality
stuff
okay yeah you could be uh
as you glide along the floor there but
we're gonna write that into
the next season
i imagine finally being able to share
the news was well worth the wait for
both of you oh definitely yes absolutely
of course we know muriel and farizan are
pretty major characters in the history
of numenor so can you tease exactly
where we find them at the very beginning
of the series what are some of their
personal top priorities and chief
concerns when episode one opens up
so farazon
is the uh cousin to queen muriel who is
the queen regent
so tarpan palantir your father is still
king but he's ill so
muriel is running numenor i'm her
counsel her right-hand man
so it is for me to make sure that the
relationship between regency
and the people of numenor run smoothly
so it's all about as far as i'm
concerned social cohesion
and so we find numenor at the peak of
its power there's little discrepancies
you have the faithful people who are
faithful to the traditions the old
elvish traditions and then you have
what i like to say the innovators the
modernists the people who want to take
and trailblaze uh newman or down a path
which celebrates their roots as men and
where they're going as a race of men and
i think that's where farzon is he sees
himself as a modernist uh being a man
he's he's mortal so he's burdened by his
own mortality so for him legacy is
everything and when you see numenor when
you
see the i mean the epic scale of the
place it's almost as if you're taking a
journey through pharazon's mind you know
it's all about legacy pride that kind of
bleeds into hubris at times
and i think for medial you know there's
that difficult position of wanting to
maintain the peace and stability that
numenor is in when we first sort of are
introduced to this world
but there are rumblings you know there
is that sense that people
are kind of unsure about her and sure
about the way forward and so you do see
these sort of two ideas of tradition
versus
modernization or progress
sort of uh clash and and sort of how
these characters then make the decisions
that they make
and do so
for the fate of their people really
i'm so excited to dig into that
i'm not sure if something like this is
is helpful for both of you when you
tackle new roles but are there any i
guess like historical figures or even
past movie or television characters that
you can draw some inspiration from to
further craft these characters beyond
what you get from the source material
absolutely every time any anybody that's
in any position of power whether they're
in the past whether it's ancient rome
whether it's the british the french
empire um russian empire whether it's
with anything or even today modern
politics you know you take from
everything you sponge everything up you
know you you just drink it all in and
just let that
see where it goes see what it takes you
yeah i think there's historical
research but there's also that emotional
research and trying to really think
around you know what do people who who
actually find themselves in positions of
power how how does that
sort of
affect them on a personal level on an
emotional level and trying to sort of
you know find the truth in that because
even if you you cannot relate to being
a a leader or being royal you can relate
to the isolation around you know what it
is to sort of be the only person tasked
with with huge decisions and how those
decisions ultimately will affect other
people so i think there was both
looking at history
obviously always referring back to
tolkien's writing and then thinking
about what would i do if if this were me
in this situation and what how have i
felt in the past about certain certain
ideas or certain things so you know we
draw from all the the sources that we
can and and just put it all out there
through these characters
all right i'll wrap with this one here
so we know that your relationship is
super important to the series but who
would you say is influencing the two of
the of them their journeys the most at
the very beginning of the show other
than the two of them okay other than the
two of them what is what is um that's
that's a really good question
um
i think
i think for faraz on
it is it is the people and when you
and that that's not a cop boat that is a
genuine answer by the way i'm with you
it's it's it's the people of newman or
so
when you you you will see the people of
newman you'll see what they mean to him
and i think this is a man who
with that without them without
everything that he sees that he he
surveys
you know that that is him that is
everything about him the people the the
play the the masonry that you see
the the the fleet that they have of
ships you know everything so when you um
in the undying tales
when you read about uh there's a chapter
about like the uh description of numenor
it's as if you're seeing it through the
eyes of a numenorean that's the pride
that they have look how beautiful this
is look how great we did this because
you know elves don't have to worry about
what they build and their legacy you
know they can live forever and they can
be one maybe insepartical with with
nature and the earth whereas men they're
not going to be around forever so they
need to make a lasting impact and i
think the people and what numenor is
that influences him and that's what's
important to him and i would say for
queen medieval i would say her lineage
you know there is her father before her
and his father before him
and his mother before him and there are
certain world views that inform her
world view but at the same time she's
trying to sort of be her own her own
person
so it's that thing of your parents have
have taught you and you've understood
lessons that they've tried to impart but
you want to make your own sort of
choices
uh you know for the here and now so i
think again i'm sort of speaking in a
slightly vague way but you know without
sort of spoiling anything just to to say
that i think you know
her lineage before her very much informs
how she wants to proceed and define
herself as a leader
our days of peace
begin
we thought our joys would be unending
we thought our light
would never dim
the skies
are strange
[Music]
at this point in his life what would you
say is gil gallard's greatest strength
but then also what do you think his
greatest weaknesses that he needs to
overcome in episode one early on
ooh great question um i'd say one of his
greatest strengths it's it's true in all
the writings that he
he
is ahead of the curve in the
anticipation of evil he's he's deeply
suspicious and
weary and he kind of has this elvish
spidey sense to sense the
tentacles of evil surging beneath the
crust of the earth you know
he's the one who
can
uh see it coming
and i think
it's that's probably
uh
double-edged for him
and that he's
ever aware ever vigilant but at the same
time
it it makes him distracted and
makes him
uh
kind of clamp down on those around them
that are also beginning their
uh journeys that lead to their destiny
so i think
that it's it's one and the same you know
to be aware
is a gift but also it can
um
make you make mistakes
i did want to dig into that whole spidey
sense thing a little bit what it what is
it about his past and his experiences
that you think him that you think give
him that ability to detect evil like
that versus others out there who can't
um well it's experience you know
thousands and thousands of years of
seeing everyone you know and love die
and the inevitable
resurrection of evil
how do you in spite of that
still
muster the strength to have hope and
that's unique to him but at the same
time
um
[Music]
it it must weigh on him all the time you
know it's
it's the ability to
hear frequencies that others can't it
must be maddening and
also when you
can sense evil and everyone's having a
party it must be infuriating you know
that that it's um
when people start taking peace for
granted um whether it's in tolkien or in
television or in the world at large
that's when we really get into trouble
and i think gilgaled understood that in
a deeply profound way
so i'm sure some of that might be very
frustrating for him to experience but he
has one quality that really stands out
that i love so much it's this idea that
he brings out the best in everyone
around him and you know it does feel
like a skill that everyone today could
benefit from learning more about so how
exactly does he go about doing that for
the people around him
well take his relationship with elrond
for example um
he
not sound condescending but he does kind
parent him
in the way a truly loving parent would
which is to encourage you to be your
better self
and uh provide you a structure with
within which you have freedom you know
that he's he's loving and brave enough
to let elrond
make mistakes
and also
it it's the way a parent can manipulate
you to be your better self
um like in any loving relationship you
want to bring out the best in each other
like you just said but sometimes to do
that you have to convince the other
person it was their idea
life lesson that can apply to this show
and every single thing out there i love
it so obviously we're going to get the
opportunity to explore many different
settlements in this show so what is it
about his kingdom that makes it stand
out from the others what are some of its
defining factors
well
four elves works of beauty their
language music their architecture they
are in a sense
weapons against evil if you imagine
lindon being
this beacon of light
constantly searching in the darkness for
where evil is hiding that that the more
beauty they put into the universe the
slower the rebirth of of evil becomes
and uh i think he really believes that
and
and the elves are that powerful
that their music uh the way they carry
themselves and the way they
preserve and
adorn middle earth
is a manifestation of good against evil
and i got a touchdown to see that in all
of its splendor
i got to touch on the scale and scope of
the show as well here so you've
obviously been on some pretty big sets
over the years i just mentioned in the
heart of the sea at the beginning
what is it about the production process
on the rings of power that's specific to
this show something that with even all
your experience you've never seen
something made this particular way
one of my first
days on set there were
200 300 000 hand-cut painted silk leaves
on the ground
and
you'd pick one up and and i don't mean
like they spray-painted them i mean
these were all individually painted they
all had a little life of their own i
knew there had been meetings about size
shape there had been options that had
been discarded and now these are the
ones they settled on and here they are
in all of their glory um
the the attention to detail and the army
of artists and craftspeople that have
been brought together to bring this to
life
has been exhilarating and humbling at
the same time
um i'm not saying that on other projects
we don't have people who come together
who are the best of the best uh but i've
never seen
it on this scale and i've never
um felt that in every department
were
all unified with one vision which is
telling tolkien's story as
close to what we imagined that he would
have wanted
that we're doing justice to it and
showing respect and
contributing to the love that we already
feel about his work and that
um
we know that fans have had for years
eventually one or the other
must surely break
you have been told many lies
so to kick us off here we know the
harfords are ancient ancestors of the
hobbits so can you guys give us a sense
of what life is like for them and maybe
how it differs from what we know of the
hobbits yeah so i mean
physically the hobbits have you know
they share similarities with the half
foot you know they both have the big
feet and they have the ears and
that's quite that will be quite familiar
but i think that um i think the
difference lies or the main difference
at least lies in their circumstances so
the hobbits have the shire and they have
that as their home whereas the harfords
are still
you know they're a nomadic community and
they're still navigating
finding a stable sense of place and
their home so that's kind of the main
the main disparity i'd say and um
and you know we you know migrate with
the seasons and
uh we're filled with a lot of love and
joy and heart we're really united
because of our circumstances and our
vulnerability um to the world around us
and the environment and so
yeah we're just
i mean the halfway it's not we but then
harford's just navigating with
given the given the links that you just
named there were there any opportunities
to kind of draw inspiration from some of
the hobbits that we've seen before in
terms of nori and poppy's individual
personalities but also your connection
to one another and your friendship
i think it was really nice to sort of
have
that them in context to sort of like
understand the world that tolkien had
created but i mean for me at least
because they're not canon characters i
was able to really build poppy from the
ground upwards um and i was able to
really feel her in my bones um sort of
through movement and through um our
dialect and not to mention like the
costumes and the hair and makeup just
like the whole transformation um
and then also you know getting to work
with markella like the bond that we have
is so strong and
you know like we we just work really
well together um yeah we were able to
really explore that especially being in
new zealand um being in a place where we
sort of had to become each other's
support systems um
yeah no it was yeah really exciting
i love hearing that i'm i'm a big
believer in the value of a strong scene
partner and to me that's what you just
described there which seems vital to
their friendship in the show
yeah i mean we yeah we didn't we didn't
have a chemistry test and we kind of
just met like a month before filming and
yeah very grateful that we
we get on
i want to hear it so markella of course
a big thing at the beginning of the show
is their encounter with this mysterious
stranger poppy's got some apprehension
when approaching him but nori doesn't so
what
where does that come from what is it
that's drawing her to him then
well so i think nori nori
nori i mean you know she's she's tricky
one but she's a really resolute and
curious inquisitive halfway she just
wants to subvert half tradition and i
really wanted to ground her in that
instead of it just being a
curiosity purely for selfish reasons i
wanted it to be i think it would have
been really
i just didn't want it to be easy in the
sense that you know she's she's
obviously
young and and i didn't want it to come
across as naive and the writing was so
brilliant that it didn't do that but i
just wanted to really lean into the idea
that she wants to find a way to improve
the quality of life for the whole
community and
that kind of leads her to adventure as
well and she kind of leads with the idea
that the fear of risk can be greater
than the risk itself sometimes
so to
go with that and push with that so i
think it's what draws her i mean
there'd be so many times where i'd read
the script and just be like why
just go and do this on your own why
dragging other people other than you
know popping into your mess just let her
be but um i do think that it's it's she
thinks it's for the greater good and she
really does have the best of intentions
um and i think that's kind of what
what draws her she's just is so
has such an innate curiosity and you
know the unknown and and that's what
initially draws her
to the stranger into that
setting
with that in mind obviously these two
characters have a lot of growing to do
over the course of the series can you
each name their greatest strength but
also their greatest weakness when we
first meet them in the show
as in for each other or for our own
characters
i kind of like the idea of flipping it
around but maybe to make it easier for
your own characters
um
i think
poppy's greatest
oh no i don't know greater strength and
then greatest weakness yeah
i think
uh
her weakness is food
she sees a berry she stops sheets
um i think their greatest strengths are
relatable yeah exactly um no i think her
greatest strength is
i mean she just has so much loyalty and
love for her friend which actually can
also be a weakness too
in the sense that sort of poppy's
drive through the series is definitely
navigated by
nori and the decisions that nori makes
um and poppy feels that it's safer to
keep her safe the community safe and
nori safe to keep her by her side and
just look out for her so i think
probably
yeah the loyalty and love that she has
for nori can definitely equal equate to
both
yeah
yeah i would say i would say that nori's
rebellion is probably her strength and
her hubris i think that it's kind of
i think that there's you have to
sacrifice something when you're
rebelling against something right so i
think for her it's it's
she even though she has the best of
intentions she can put other people in
in danger and put other people at risk
and so i think
um
that that can be
that can be frustrating sometimes
because you can see what she's trying to
do
but she's just not she's still learning
and growing and doesn't have
um
full awareness of of the consequences of
her decisions
um and her decision-making sometimes so
i think yeah i think her rebellion can
be both as well
find the light and the shadow will not
find you
together we can survive this
fight with me
each of us
must decide who we shall be
so your characters share a forbidden
relationship in it
why are elf human relationships looked
at that way and what is it about their
connection to one another that inspires
them to fight for it
i think in in
the history of
i mean the lore history of elves and
humans
and tolkien when you're referred to
talking it's only happened a few times
and it's and it's ended in uh
not so well i mean it's like tragedy and
sometimes in charge sometimes in death
so it's it's it has happened very few
times and for very specific reasons and
that carries on our second age show as
well but in our show um without giving
too much away
that's the thing i mean i have to answer
the question like
i don't envy you today you know so i i i
and then i i'm trying to track it um my
inner show i mean that that rings true
as well but um there's also
several layers of
of why it's forbidden for us i play out
on beer silva nelf that has been
tasked with watching over the people of
the southlands you know they've been
centuries ago they chose the side of
evil and then since then we've been
watching over these people making sure
that the law you know they stay
stay put you know it pretty much
occupied their land so that in and of
itself creates this power dynamic
between
us
that makes it also extra extra forbidden
okay how about for you and as an in what
is what is something about
aaron dear that
that maybe bronwyn needs in her life
right now a specific quality that he has
that's that's good for her at this point
i mean it's really interesting because
he has as a person the quiet strength
that he brings to the screen as add-on
dear and i think what is the cliche is
that the the the male character comes in
and sweeps the woman off her feet and
that she's demure and she's you know and
this is the opposite of that you've got
someone i i feel like bronwyn is the
more vocal one arondir has that quiet
strength there's very many
as well
um she's
vocal and she's strong and she's sort of
um
um
very frank and
asks questions in a way that's direct
and and here's this warrior courageous
warrior who has a very quiet strength
who is an elf of very few words
everything is conveyed in looks and
movement
and um with me there's uh this with
bronwyn there's sort of um that that
sort of in-your-face feistiness and fire
that you see and this equal footing of
human without any magical powers and
this elf with magical powers
despite the power differential between
them is so fascinating and i love that
she's an empowered woman with this
powerful help
well she does have a particular set of
skills that is very important even if
they aren't powers like an elf might
have so what does it mean to be a healer
in this world and i guess what are some
of the defining elements about what it
means to practice medicine in this realm
i mean it's so interesting because i am
i was pre-med so i have a degree in
biology and i i resin it resonates with
me that she's also trying to liberate
her people from you know the shadows of
their past and
um i'm an activist and i've done a lot
of work for my homeland iran um
and so
there's so much in here that i can
relate to
and i think it's super important that
when i when you look at the women of
iran they are at the forefront of this
movement towards freedom and democracy
and we call them shuzan which is lioness
so i tap into sort of my inner lioness
when i play bronwyn um it means the
world to me that she
has the the courage of her convictions
um and there's a fearlessness in both of
them in exploring
the other the the forbidden um that i
love and and you look at us and you
think on screen that this elf and human
should not be because they're so
different and their worlds are so
different but there's a humanity that or
there's a there's a underlying core
value system that binds us and bonds us
um and that's a beautiful message for
today's world because you you
should never judge a book by its cover
we have more in common than divides us
what a beautiful description i'll wrap
with a question for both of you here so
you get the opportunity to play entirely
original characters which does sound
very exciting from a creative
perspective but it also might be a
little daunting given how beloved these
characters and this world are so what is
something new that they each bring to
this world that you're especially
excited for viewers to see for the first
time but then on the other hand what is
something that you strove to do with
your characters so they feel like
natural extensions of this world we know
yeah i think the characters are written
were very much on the following the the
legacy of tolkien you know so it's uh
they belong there you know it wasn't
just pulled out of different references
there the lore is extremely deep and
extremely detailed for for these
characters to be formed in certain gaps
or or or from different references so i
think that took care of itself in that
sense that the creators of the show did
a great job at that we researched very
deeply in terms of that but also i mean
there was incredible possibility in in
in in bringing layers
um and and perhaps grit uh humanity and
bringing soul to these roles and because
it's the medium of tv as you said you
get to have more time
to uh to sit and watch
uh and live
and tether yourself and see yourself
with these characters and what they
represent and what they bring
yeah agreed
the past is dead
we either move forward
or we die with it
this could be the beginning of a new era
i'll throw this one to you to kick us
off here so supposedly during the second
age the dwarves are in a very strong and
powerful place so can you kind of paint
a picture for us of what high times in
the dwarf kingdom look like at the very
start of the series
yeah
correct you know it's it's a golden age
for
doom so um you see us um
trading a lot of um
a lot of
metal um and rock and um
it's you see the ins and outs of khazad
doom
um
water lights and
a very thriving world
okay i'm eager to dig into that more
sophia for you now can you tell us a
little bit about the relationship
between doran and diesel not just what
their personal dynamic is like but also
how their approaches to politics and the
kingdom differ too you know they're they
are so united um what's so wonderful is
that they want the same things um they
want the same things but they um
challenge and throw ideas about how we
are going to get there um and that is
led with a
immeasurable amount of power and passion
and love and heart um
uh and unapologetic shows of emotion
they are very much in love um and very
much still have the hots for each other
so um
and so um
you power couple there are we're a power
coupler
we're a power couple and we're not
afraid to shut it
i mean i don't know if it's too early to
play favorites but i feel like that
description kind of just made the two of
you my favorites
a dwarf and a sales woman
it's old over here how about when it
comes to their interactions uh with
other kingdoms out there at this point
do doran and diesel have any really
strong feelings about you know what
other individuals like gilgallit and
elrond and others are up to right now
well the the traits of the dwarves is
that they don't trust anybody
on the outside of their own world so
um that's you know that quality is very
much still there there are a few
exceptions and we shall find out
and that um
but but we trade with the outside world
as well you know so so we kind of we
need each other we need we we need the
middle earth for for middle earth to
work
everybody need each needs each other but
we've already established you to have
each other and it sounds to me like
that's all you need in the world yeah
that's true that's true
always putting a silver lining on these
tough times in these shows so sophia one
thing that i am especially eager to see
play out here based on the footage we
got to see was how the dwarves singing
traditions are incorporated in the
narrative so are you able to tease that
for us a little how that all plays out
into the uh the story here of course
there are um there are many ways um uh
but one of them uh the one that sticks
with me because um uh you know like i
got too exciting you brilliantly play it
was that um
princess deezer and uh some of the
dwarven women can resonate um and
resonating is a method used whereby they
draw sound from the depths of their
dwarven soul to be able to only some
female dwarves female doors that are in
a position of power possess that that
that that superpower um and they are
able to speak to and gain knowledge from
the materials around them so from the
rocks from the stone from the waters
from the gold you know they are able to
hear what they need and also um
be informed by their movements and so
you will see um
princess diesel in all her vocal glory
um uh uh shining and and resonating
those powers i'm especially excited for
that part of this for both of you now
can you give us a sense of some of the
filming techniques used for you know
scenes outside of the dwarf kingdom or
when you're with other non-dwarf
characters because i know in the films
they use things like forced perspective
and also some digital effects so what is
the filming process for like for that
like on rings of power compared to the
film series
well those methods are are still
certainly in
um because they are effective and useful
um
but we we did all of them we
experimented ever with every avenue and
uh we were fortunate enough to have a
great team
who wanted you know everybody was
thriving for it to be the best that it
possibly can
and that meant you know what would help
is that if we would have eye contact
whilst the welsh
whilst acting with each other sometimes
yes of course you can't avoid but look
at tennis ball and act with a tennis
ball sometimes
but um but it's all part of the
excitement
you felt like a little
a little kid playing with toys you know
when when when those days and those
tricks happened